(upbeat music)
- Families, friends,
esteemed faculty and staff,
welcome to Yale College Class Day.
And most importantly,
to the Class of 2021,
on behalf of me, Skye,
Steven, Jin, and Stanley,
we just want to say congratulations.
For over 100 years,
Yalies have come together
and celebrated our graduating class
one last time on Class Day.
I don't need to tell you
that this year's ceremony,
much like our senior year,
looks a little different
from its predecessors,
but in today's festivities,
we hope to replicate and renovate
many of Yale's most cherished traditions.
We'll start today off
with a series of speeches
from graduates and alumni.
Vy Tran will open our
ceremony with the Ivy Ode.
Then we'll hear from acclaimed
songwriter Bobby Lopez,
our Senior Class Council,
and a comedic reflection
by Matt Nadel and Teava Torres de Sa.
To cap off the day and our time at Yale,
Alec Zbornak will deliver a reflection
on these last four years
we've shared together.
But before we begin, I
wanted to take a moment
to walk you through some of the items
you received yesterday.
The Class Anthology,
produced by Skye Ward,
details our time together
in a series of essays and works of art.
The Churchwarden Pipe,
a tradition that dates back to the 1860s,
used to symbolize the end
of a carefree college life
as successive generations
of Yalies would form circles
and crush the pipes into the earth.
The sprig of ivy ties us back to
the ceremonial planting of the Class Ivy,
a tradition that began way back in 1852
to symbolize the abiding
legacy of our contributions
to the college, even
long after we graduate.
And lastly, the Yale handkerchief,
which Skye will tell you more about
at the end of our ceremony here today.
Yale has changed a lot since
these traditions first began.
It's even changed in the few short years
that we've been a part of it,
but there are some parts of it
that will always remain constant.
Here to remind us of this
enduring spirit of Yale
is Vy Tran, a senior in Branford College
studying Ethnicity, Race, and
Migration, with our Ivy Ode.
- There's a specific feeling
of coming back to campus
after being gone for awhile.
Sometimes it's been a long Uber ride
from Hartford or LaGuardia or JFK.
Sometimes it's an Uber ride
after a train ride into Union Station.
Sometimes it's in a car
your family's driving in
that you've known your entire life.
Sometimes it's in the
car you're driving in
with your friends, coming back from a trip
you're still trying to revel in
and your body is itching to get up
because you've been sitting for hours.
And pulling through Chapel or York or Elm,
you know the streets,
but they also feel a little
bit different this time.
It's the same feeling of
walking into your childhood home
after six months in New Haven and swearing
that your head is a tiny
bit closer to the ceiling.
It's the same feeling as
hugging your family again
and wanting to show them that
you're a little bit different
but that you're also the same.
There's a specific feeling
of hearing a voice you love
pop up in your common room.
It's Thursday, and you hear
your suite door open and close
and you think it's your suitemate
just coming back from the bathroom,
but it's actually someone else.
There's a specific joy at hearing a voice
that isn't coming out of
your computer speakers.
It's the same feeling as hearing
one of your favorite songs
start to play at a party.
(Remember those?)
Or on the radio in the car,
or on your friend's phone
that's connected to the Bluetooth speaker
in the living room.
And as many times as I've
heard Carrie Underwood's
"Before He Cheats" or Sage
the Gemini's "Gas Pedal,"
the songs never don't hit.
It's the same feeling as
hearing that one of your friends
got that job they were excited
for and you are so excited
for everything that's coming their way.
There's a specific feeling of seeing
one of your favorite
people on Cross Campus,
looking cute and all.
You see someone you're pretty
sure is who you think it is,
but especially now with masks,
I really don't know if
we're on the "hi" level
or if we're on the walk-past-each-other-
and-act-like-we're-looking-at-
something-over-there level.
But sometimes it really is
someone you know and love
and can be excited for, unabashedly.
And they're excited to see you too.
It's the same feeling as
seeing red chat pop up
in your Zoom because someone has DM-ed you.
And it's the feeling of
watching your friends smile
at your message in response,
or both of you covering your faces
and turning your cameras
off because you're laughing
at the wrong thing at the wrong time.
It's the same feeling as
losing your person at a party
or a weird Yale event
that you're much more
socially anxious about than
you're willing to admit,
but then you turn around and you see them
and they were looking for you too.
A while ago, I was coming
back from a retreat
with a wonderful group of people.
And on their way back to
New Haven, someone was like,
"What if X person had come?
Do you think that would
have made any difference?"
And then someone was like, "Of course.
They always make a difference.
Everyone makes a difference."
And I think about that a lot,
because especially in a place like Yale,
it's so easy to think
that you could go missing
for a few days and no one would notice.
And every other day for
the past four years,
I've thought about disappearing
to go live on a farm
and paint and read books
and sit with goats.
But if there's anything
I've learned at Yale,
it's that I am only a sum of
everyone that I've ever loved.
No one here knows what they're doing
or who they are or what they want in life.
The things that we think are worth it
and the things that we're
taught will satisfy us
and the job and the salary
and all these other things
that we think Yale is supposed to be for
don't make Yale Yale.
In reality, the things that make Yale Yale
are the people that we love
and the ways that we love them.
We look forward to the
little things with them.
We look forward to seeing
if there's bacon at brunch...
if your house favorite will
win "The Bachelor"... (They don't.)
If that thing you ordered has finally
come into the packaging center...
and if it's finally gonna
be nice enough this weekend
to go to the farmer's market in Wooster
with your friends like you
always say you want to.
And in truth, life a week from now
could be exactly the same
or drastically different.
And while we don't always
know what we're doing,
we do know what we feel.
We feel happy and sad and
stressed and exhausted
and tired of the snow
and tired of the cold.
We feel joy and pride
and love and loneliness
and that we're growing up too fast
and there's no way to stop this train.
But if you look outside,
you'll see that the view is beautiful.
There's a specific feeling
of leaving campus after
being here for awhile.
And when I next see Elm
Street, I will feel older.
There's that weird conversation
starter that's like,
"If you could say anything
to your younger self,
what would you say?"
And I think I would say "I'm so proud.
We've come so far and done so much
and loved so widely and so deeply,
and there's even more to come."
It's the same feeling as
packing up your suitcase
for the end of the semester,
or the end of Yale now,
and realizing that you're
not the same person you were
when you came here freshman year.
It's the same feeling as
taking down all your photos
and all your posters off your wall
and thinking, "I'm gonna miss this place."
There's a specific feeling
of leaving campus after
being here for awhile,
and I think it's called
growing up and leaving home.
And I wouldn't want to
do it anywhere else.
Much love to the Class of 2021.
Love y'all. We did it!
- We are delighted to
announce our renowned
Class Day speaker, Robert Lopez,
Yale College Class of 1997.
Lopez is a two-time Emmy, Grammy,
Oscar, and Tony award-winning songwriter.
After graduating from Yale College in 1997
with a bachelor's degree in English,
he joined the BMI
Musical Theatre Workshop,
where he met future
collaborators Jeff Marx,
with whom he co-created the multiple
Tony award-winning "Avenue
Q," and Kristen Anderson,
now Kristen Anderson-Lopez,
his wife and co-writer.
The couples' partnership
produced the songs
from "Frozen," "Frozen II,"
and "Marvel's WandaVision,"
as well as the song
"Remember Me" from "Coco."
Lopez is also the co-creator,
with Matt Stone and Trey
Parker of "South Park" fame,
of "The Book of Mormon,"
which debuted in 2011
and won nine Tony Awards.
He shared two Emmy Awards for his music
on Nickelodeon's "The
Wonder Pets" as well as
Emmy nominations for songs in "Scrubs,"
the 87th Academy Awards ceremony,
and the mockumentary "The Comedians."
His work has been featured
on the television shows
"South Park," "The Simpsons,"
and "Phineas & Ferb."
Lopez is one of only 15 artists to win
all four major entertainment
industry awards,
Emmy, Grammy, Oscar, and Tony.
He was also the youngest
to do so, at age 39 in 2014,
and the first to win
all four a second time.
He's been an amazing ambassador for
the artistic talents and activities
that are such a big part
of the Yale experience.
Without further ado, please
help me welcome Robert Lopez.
- Hello, congratulations,
and happy Class Day,
Yale College Class of 2021.
I want to thank President Salovey
and everyone at Yale for the
honor of speaking to you today.
Actually, this is gonna
be taped over many days,
and I have a lot of these shirts,
so I think that we will be fine
with the illusion of continuity.
So my Class Day in 1997, it rained,
and we all sat in chairs
for hours with umbrellas,
which is something I've never done since.
I hope it doesn't rain
today, but if it does,
please take my advice and don't
be talked into sitting outside.
Even with an umbrella,
you will still get wet.
My name is Robert Lopez.
Everyone calls me Bobby.
I'm a songwriter and I'm here
because the administration
and the Class Day Committee now prefers
musical theater
professionals to the typical
intellectual, historian,
politician, writer,
or entrepreneur they usually get.
And well they should, because
at this crossroads of history
a little musical theater
might be just the thing for all of us.
And they hinted, not so subtly,
that I work some songs into my remarks.
And for the majority of you who are like
"Who the eff is this guy," here is a hint.
This is a rewrite of one of my songs
to forever musicalize the
moment President Salovey
asked me to do this.
♪ Do you want to speak on Class Day ♪
♪ I think it would be fun ♪
♪ I know it's not your super power ♪
♪ To talk for half an hour
in front of everyone ♪
♪ But it would be exciting ♪
♪ And just think of all the
lessons you'd like to teach ♪
♪ Yes, I guess I'll speak on Class Day ♪
♪ And I guess I'll write this Class Day ♪
♪ Song ♪
Today is Class Day.
It's a celebration of the four
years you've spent at Yale.
New Haven has changed a lot
since my Class Day 24 years ago.
Mostly it's better.
Really, the only thing I
miss is the Yankee Doodle,
an old-fashioned lunch counter
that served magical burgers
and fried butter donuts.
God, that place was great.
I'd go in the early, early
morning for breakfast sandwiches
after pulling an all-nighter.
The only time I ever got to hang out
with people from the crew team.
I'll never forget there was
this one all-nighter I pulled.
I was writing some paper
and I left my computer on.
I used to really go through despair
while writing long papers
and I needed food to sustain my spirits.
So I came back to my room with
a soda and a bag of chips.
And I sat back down at my desk
and where my paper had left off,
there were now like a
bunch of random letters
like X-D-F-G-K-L semicolon slash slash.
I thought, "That's weird."
And then I noticed that some tissues
from a box on my desk had been shredded.
Then I looked at my window
and there was some loose dirt
and an acorn there.
And then right on the
ledge of the open window,
a squirrel sat there,
intensely looking back at me.
I screamed a bloodcurdling sound
that probably woke up the entire building
and the squirrel jumped out
the window onto a tree branch
and never returned.
Honestly, I thought about this a lot
and I think it was a Disney moment
that I was too high-strung at
the time to really appreciate.
I mean, I was stuck on a
paper and a freaking squirrel
came in and typed
something on my keyboard,
and I just screamed and
deleted what he typed.
I mean, can you imagine the song
that the squirrel would
eventually have sung
if I'd only thanked him and let him stay?
Anyway, I think the gist of
what I want to talk about today
is accepting help from
the squirrel friends
that the universe provides,
accepting collaboration into your life.
The week before my Class Day,
we had something called Senior Week.
I'm not sure if you guys were
able to have that this year,
but back in my day, you were
supposed to take a fun trip
with your best friends
to like Myrtle Beach
and party all week.
I was in the acapella
group The Spizzwinks,
and my two best friends
from my class and the Winks,
John and Brian, were sort of late
to figure out what we were gonna do.
And we ended up going to Maine,
which in May that year was
really cold and really damp.
The cabin we rented had
a sign bearing its name,
which was It'll Do.
And as we sat and froze
and did jigsaw puzzles,
the whole thing felt
like a bit of a metaphor
for what we thought life
was about to serve us.
I think we were afraid
we were going to graduate
and go our separate ways
and forget each other,
and that the real world
was gonna be like It'll Do
in May '97: cold, damp, and depressing.
I think we were afraid we'd be lonely,
that it was about to be
me against the world.
First of all, I could not have
gotten through this pandemic
without John and Brian.
Every Tuesday for the
last year we got on Zoom
and had a scotch and
helped each other deal with
whatever we had to deal with.
We've been to each other's weddings.
We've watched our kids be born.
I mean, a lot of my Yale friends and I
have stuck together and
worked together too.
And the real world may be
tough, but it was not lonely.
Sometimes school, with grades and tests,
makes you feel like work
is something you do alone.
But my experience is
that work can't be done
without collaborators.
I'm gonna talk out of
my butt for a moment.
A great surgeon has a
team of doctors and nurses
in the operating room with them.
A CEO has to manage vice presidents
and satisfy the board of directors.
A professor works within their department.
A great novelist allows a
trusted circle of friends
and ultimately an editor
to read early drafts
and give them necessary feedback.
You get the idea.
I don't think there is
any field you can go into
in which you can succeed
without working with others.
You guys have had
collaborators your whole life
without knowing it.
Your first collaborators were your family.
When you were a baby,
you were totally
dependent on your parents,
but without knowing it,
you were teaching them too.
Testing them through
your utter dependence,
forcing them to learn responsibilities
and solve problems and gain skills
they never would have learned
without a crying baby.
Helping them to level up to
be able to parent a toddler,
then a child, then a tween, then a teen,
and now finally a 20-something.
You and your family worked
together to raise you,
to get you into Yale
and get you out of Yale.
They are incredible collaborators and
they deserve credit for you
as much as you do for them.
You guys should thank each other today.
Your classmates here at
Yale are collaborators too.
You've worked in the
residential colleges together,
making life better for each other.
You've worked together to plan events
like parties and dances and protests.
You've worked together on sports teams.
I didn't do that at Yale.
You've worked together in
acapella groups and theater,
did both of those.
In newspapers, comedy
groups, political clubs,
ethnic, religious, and racial
identity forums, LGBTQ+,
even secret societies.
All of these things are
examples of collaboration.
You've been practicing it this whole time.
And when I was preparing for the speech,
I met with a faculty member
and the student committee for Class Day
and I realized another thing
you've been collaborating on.
Re-imagining Yale within
the realities of COVID.
You guys know much more about
what that's been like than I do.
And from what I've heard,
it's been very difficult and stressful,
but I just want to underline
how much collaborative work
it's taken you all to make
this past year a reality.
And I want to say I'm amazed by it.
I feel like sometimes the
subtext of education is
become well-rounded, be
skilled in everything.
Don't have weaknesses, be a
Rhodes Scholar, be incredible,
which I think in many
ways is a great message
and that it leads to you
working to better yourself,
which is really important.
But at some point, you know,
everyone has weaknesses.
It's called being human.
After you graduate, you may struggle
in the real world for a few years.
I certainly did.
I bumped up big-time into my weaknesses.
I tend to be shy, an introvert.
My daughter says I'm INFP.
My wife says I'm a typical Pisces.
And when I graduated,
the buzzword for how to
get ahead was networking.
Everyone said network, network, network,
which to me sounded awful.
The thought of going to cocktail parties
and walking up to people
and giving them my card,
I would just rather do
anything other than that.
My other weakness was that I still
wasn't fully baked as a songwriter.
Since I was 13 years old,
I had been writing songs
that were very good,
but very good imitations
of Stephen Sondheim.
Like this one.
♪ Ladies and gentlemen, I've
got wonderful news for you ♪
♪ We're about to start ♪
I didn't yet have a voice of my own.
So even if I did give someone
my card or my demo tape
and they heard my songs,
they'd be like, "That's great.
It sounds like Stephen Sondheim."
It's okay to have weaknesses.
It's okay to be shy.
It's okay to not be fully
baked as a songwriter.
It's okay to have a hard time
writing a 25-minute long speech,
because if you find community
and if you find collaborators,
you can partner with people who are strong
in the areas you struggle in.
I joined a class that taught
musical theater writing
called the BMI Musical Theatre Workshop.
And my classmates in that
class became my friends
and collaborators, and helped
me find my voice as a writer.
My collaborator Jeff Marx
was the kind of person
who thrived on networking,
who loved promoting our team
and never felt self-conscious
handing anyone a demo tape.
Writing in the same room with Jeff
brought out a different
side of my personality,
one that was more like
who I was making jokes
and laughing with the Spizzwinks at Yale.
So instead of my default, which
was to write like Sondheim,
I ended up having a lot more fun.
And what we wrote came
out fresher and more real.
And together, we wrote
a show that was inspired
by a lot of the feelings
we were both having
struggling in the real world.
And that show went to Broadway.
In that show, "Avenue Q,"
a puppet has just graduated college
and is standing on the
stage in cap and gown
holding his degree.
He is meant to be just like you guys,
except a little bit lamer.
His name is Princeton.
(gentle music)
♪ What do you do with a B.A. in English ♪
♪ What is my life going to be ♪
♪ Four years of college
and plenty of knowledge ♪
♪ Have earned me this useless degree ♪
♪ I can't pay the bills yet
'cause I have no skills yet ♪
♪ The world is a big scary place ♪
♪ But somehow I can't shake
the feeling I might make ♪
♪ A difference to the human race ♪
I think in this moment of commencement
and a new chapter of life
beginning for all of you,
there's also the illusion of
a starter pistol going off
and a mad dash to market yourself
and sell what you have and what you are.
And there's a lot of
truth to this metaphor.
And a lot of what's great
about America lies in that race
and the spirit of trying
to outshine the competition
and sparkle the brightest.
Many, if not all of you are
indeed special, sparkly diamonds
discovered by the Yale
admissions department
and cut and polished by
four years of education,
now looking to be set in
gorgeous fine jewelry.
Some of you may prefer
a more masculine image,
and you can feel free to
invent that on your own.
Any rate, what I'm trying to
say is that talent, craft,
and ability need to be
channeled into purpose.
Of course, you are all
talented in your particular way
or you wouldn't be here.
For me, I tried to write
the cleverest lyrics
with puns and jokes and inner rhymes.
I would search for new chords
I'd never heard before in a song,
musical flourishes and crazy
rhythms that would stand out.
And now when I listen to
that old stuff, I cringe,
because it's just all about trying to
attract attention and show off.
The subtext of it was "hire me."
It was an immature way of writing
and it had no purpose beyond itself.
The true purpose of music
is not to serve yourself,
but give something real and emotional
to your fellow human being.
And I learned this not from my
parents, not from a teacher,
not from a friend, but
from a paper I wrote
about Shakespeare's "Tempest"
in my senior year of Yale.
This was my senior thesis in English,
and I promise you I did not approach it
with the idea of learning anything.
I was just trying to
fulfill the requirement,
get my degree, and get on with it.
So in "The Tempest," there's
a character named Prospero,
a powerful magician who
lives in exile on an island.
And he has this servant named Ariel
who is sort of a fairy spirit made of air.
Prospero sends Ariel out
to do his magical bidding
and influence the other
characters on the island,
his purpose being complicated,
but basically to redeem
himself by creating harmony
in the lives of the other characters.
And Ariel is always singing,
and in many ways represents music.
In my research, I found
that in the Renaissance,
the line between academic
professor and magician was blurry,
as was the line between music and magic.
And I came across the work of
a Renaissance philosopher named Ficino,
who was famous for singing magical songs
and whose idea was that music
was a form of airy spirit,
kind of like Ariel, that could
fly between the singer and us
and influence our own spirits,
because both were made
of the same thing, air.
The word "inspire" itself was
very central to all of this.
Anyway, I don't think
it was a great paper.
I didn't even pick it up to see my grade
or read the comments because
I was kind of ashamed
of how half-baked it was.
But for the rest of my life,
every time I've sat down to write a song,
it's never been about trying
to get hired or get noticed.
I think about the magic
power that music has to heal,
to inspire, to influence, to ensnare,
all those things that Prospero
could do, music can do.
And ever since I started doing that,
ever since I started trying
to reach out with music
and help people with it, like magic,
I started being more successful.
I think this is true of anything
any of you want to do in life.
It needs to be of
service to the community.
It needs to fulfill a function,
to make people's lives better in some way.
And if it does that, people will value it
and people will value you.
Kristen and I were
thinking about this idea
when we wrote the song
"Remember Me" from "Coco."
The first time we heard it,
first time we hear it in the movie,
the great Ernesto de la Cruz
is singing a farewell to the audience,
showing off for the
ladies and hamming it up.
♪ Remember me ♪
That kind of thing.
But later we hear, spoiler alert,
that the song was not written by Ernesto
but by a poor musician named Hector
that was forced to leave
his wife and little daughter
when he went out on the road,
and wrote her a lullaby to
make sure she always knew
he always loved her even when he was away.
♪ Remember me ♪
♪ Though I have to say goodbye ♪
♪ Don't let it make you cry ♪
♪ For even if I'm far away
I hold you in my heart ♪
♪ I sing a secret song to
you each night we are apart ♪
♪ Remember me ♪
♪ Though I have to travel far ♪
♪ Each time you hear a sad guitar ♪
♪ Know that I'm with you
the only way that I can be ♪
♪ Until you're in my arms again ♪
♪ Remember me ♪
So when you sit down to work
on something with someone,
what's the worst thing that can happen>
Is it that the work goes badly,
that you waste a few hours
or even a whole day making
something you aren't proud of?
Or is it that you might hurt the feelings
of the person you're working with?
So the rule I had always operated by,
which seemed logical to
my ambitious, driven,
stressed-out Yale brain was
that the most important thing
when you sit down to
write a song is the song.
As long as the song turns
out great, anything goes,
which meant for me and my collaborators,
we had to have any power
struggle, painful criticism,
or knock-down, drag-out fight
that could help the song.
Things took as long as they took
and our feelings weren't important.
And operating by this rule,
I wrote lots of good songs
with lots of great people,
but I noticed that those collaborations
tended to run into trouble long term
when bad feelings would
accumulate over time.
So one day Kristen and I were
writing a song on a particular project
and we were having our
usual fight for control.
And I told myself "Today,
Kristen matters more than this song.
I won't stifle myself creatively,
but I won't fight for anything.
And we'll try every
idea that everyone has.
Who cares if you write a bad song?"
So Kristen said, "I want to use
the four chords of awesome."
For those of you who don't know,
those are the pop hit chords.
The one, five, minor six, four.
And I had never allowed us to use them
because I thought they were
like musical MSG, just too easy.
But today we are gonna try every idea.
I knew she was going for something.
And this is what we wrote when
I decided to treat Kristen
as more important than
the song we were writing.
♪ Let it go, let it go ♪
♪ I am one with the wind and sky ♪
♪ You'll never see me cry ♪
♪ Here I stand and here I'll stay ♪
♪ Let the storm rage on ♪
♪ My power flurries through
the air into the ground ♪
♪ My soul is spiraling in
frozen fractals all around ♪
♪ And one thought crystallizes
like an icy blast ♪
♪ I'm never going back,
the past is in the past ♪
♪ Let it go, let it go ♪
♪ And I'll rise like the break of dawn ♪
♪ That perfect girl is gone ♪
♪ Here I stand in the light of day ♪
♪ Let the storm rage on ♪
♪ The cold never bothered me anyway ♪
That song was more fun to write
than anything we'd ever written.
It was a joyful, happy process,
and it allowed Kristen's
perspective as an artist
and a feminist to change
a world a teeny bit.
The people you work with
are always more important
than the work you're doing.
There is only benefit when
you value them that way.
So I've talked a lot
today about collaboration.
I hope it's been helpful
and I hope you go out there
and knock our socks off.
I know you will.
Like everything else I've ever done,
I had help with this, and I want to end
by thanking everyone who helped
me get this speech together.
Yale and President Salovey
for asking me to do it.
Alison Coleman and the students
on the Class Day Committee
who coached me on it, my
friends, my family, my kids,
and especially my closest collaborator,
my partner and wife,
Kristen Anderson-Lopez.
No Kristen, no speech.
And finally, that squirrel
from my dorm room?
Well, it's taken me 24 years,
but to thank him, I
finally memorialized him
with his own Disney-style song
where he sings his message to me,
and I'd like to sing it now for you
to close this out as sort
of a squirrely benediction
on what has been an amazing day.
♪ Don't give up when you're stuck ♪
♪ Take my help, what the ___ ♪
♪ I may be just a
squirrel, but dammit girl ♪
♪ I'll help you through ♪
♪ Help me help you ♪
♪ Don't be above collaboration ♪
♪ After your graduation ♪
♪ Be someone else's squirrel ♪
♪ Give that tail a swirl
and help them too ♪
♪ Help them help you ♪
♪ You've been through more than anyone ♪
♪ Yale College Class of '21 ♪
♪ Bright college years
with pleasure rife ♪
♪ The shortest, gladdest years of life ♪
♪ Now go into the world,
but do it squirreled ♪
♪ You'll sail right through if you ♪
♪ Help them help you ♪
(bright music)
Boola boola!
- Hello, Class of 2021.
I'm Bryan Owens, your class secretary.
- And I'm Curtis Colvett,
your class treasurer.
- And we are both very excited
to share this day with you.
- Class of 2021, what
a privilege it's been
to be the historic largest class
ever to enter Yale College.
We were essentially the
vanguard of a new era at Yale,
a new era not because Yale
is fundamentally changed,
but because it has grown.
Become more inclusive, more accessible,
to offer more opportunity for all.
Case in point, even in
2017, when we were freshmen,
Durfee Market expanded its
meal swipe from $8 to $9
and many other wonderful
changes and developments
have been happening all around us.
We were the first class
to live all four years
in Ben Franklin and Pauli Murray Colleges.
Simultaneously, facilities
all around campus
have been expanding and
shifting their roles.
Schwarzman Center, which has been closed
essentially since we've been here
will nonetheless open very soon
to students for generations to come.
Science Hill has all
kinds of new facilities
for state-of-the-art research.
The Tobin Economic Center will soon open.
The future of Yale looks really bright
and it's a privilege to have
been one of the first classes
to experience Yale in this new phase.
- When we think back to Yale,
we will inevitably remember
the trials and tribulations
of the past four years,
and especially of the
past year and a half.
Our class braved this
once-in-a-century pandemic
and we've grown resilient because of it.
We created ways to ensure
that social distancing
does not mean becoming antisocial.
"Let's catch up after the pandemic"
became the new "Let's
grab a meal sometime."
We survived months of Zoom lectures,
lying in bed half awake, camera
off and microphone muted.
- And this weekend we're
gonna be saying goodbye
to our time living in these
14 residential colleges.
The memories and the friendships
are gonna last a lifetime,
but this constant
closeness of being together
in one nice beautiful town is going away.
We'll remember the professors
who have shaped our lives,
the faculty and staff who
have taken care of us,
and all those conversations
that we had at random times
in the day and night, being
in the basement of Bass
or being in the slightly
less dark upstairs of Bass,
possibly even walking down
what Mark Twain once called
the most beautiful street in
America, Hillhouse Avenue.
- Many of us will feel a wistful emptiness
as we lose our core identity
of being a Yale student,
but our connections with
Yale will only grow stronger
as we build our new
identities as Yale alumni.
We will join a group of
people dedicated to service,
leadership, and education.
And if there's anything
that COVID has taught us,
it's that we are all in this together.
So please, stay in touch with the people
who have touched your lives,
and at the same time make new friends
at your regional Yale Clubs
and alumni interest groups.
Even consider becoming a mentor
to the next classes of Yalies.
And of course, we welcome you to join us
at our Class of 2021 alumni events.
We hope to see you there.
We'd like to take one last second to thank
the family and friends who
devoted their time and energy
to making us into the
adults that we are today.
They've shaped the Class of
2021 in so many wonderful ways.
We'd also like to think
Yale administration
for sticking with us this difficult year,
helping us to make the most out of it,
for ensuring that we had a safe, fun,
and memorable senior year.
But above all, it's been
our pleasure to serve
as your senior class officers.
- Once again.
- [Both] Congratulations and good luck
to the Class of 2021.
- Hey, everyone.
Obviously Harvard-Yale
is one of the best weekends of the year,
and some of my fondest memories
from first year, actually,
with Angelica and
Lauren, was waiting in line
for the bus to the
stadium for over an hour.
And I may or may not
have ordered and canceled
three or four Ubers.
- It's just one of those Yale traditions
that really brings everyone together.
You look up when you're
sitting in the student section
and realize that you're part
of this amazing community
and that you have so
much to be grateful for.
- And of course we all
missed it this year,
but we will for sure be back next,
remembering that the weekend
is a marathon and not a sprint.
(upbeat music)
- I have the pleasure of
introducing this year's speakers
for the comedic reflection.
Teava Torres de Sa from
Hopper College is graduating
with a bachelor of science in mathematics.
Matt Nadel, also from Hopper College,
is graduating with a bachelor
of arts in American studies,
which he insists is just
as employable as math.
The two of them wrote the speech
in their dark basement apartment,
fueled by an unending
passion for the Class of 2021
and a group of friends
who contributed jokes
and offered edits on every draft.
When asked about their writing process,
Matt and Teava said, "We wrote many jokes,
and to the relief of
the Class Day committee,
only some of them are in this speech."
But I have to say, having
seen the two of them
work together on the speech,
the only thing that's stronger
than the jokes you're about to hear
is their obvious love for
each other as suitemates.
So with that, I'll turn
it over to Matt and Teava
to deliver this year's comedic reflection.
- President Salovey, Dean Chun,
esteemed administrators and faculty,
Yale friends and family, and
members of the Class of 2021,
today is a day for pride:
pride in our alma mater,
pride in our classmates,
and pride in ourselves.
- I, for one, am a proud Latino Yalie,
child of immigrants, who made
his way to the Ivy League
against all odds.
- And I, um.
Yeah, I'm actually just gonna go.
- Matt, come back!
You have so much to be proud of!
You're a great student. You're funny.
You're a pillar of the LGBT community.
- You think I'm a pillar?
- It's good to have you back.
Matt and I have known each
other for quite some time.
- In fact, we met on August 25th, 2017,
the first day of our first year at Yale.
- We were randomly assigned roommates
coming to Yale from opposite
sides of the country.
- I'm sure you remember the excitement
of meeting your first-year roommate.
Your dad was in the common room
putting together a Sandbacken from Ikea.
- Your mom was disinfecting
every bathroom in Bingham Hall.
- And you were beginning
a lifelong friendship
that would definitely
never become hostile.
- I certainly remember it.
For me and Matt, it was
love at first sight.
I mean, Tinder? Ship?
Datamatch? Forget 'em.
If you really want to find love,
put your faith in Jeremiah Quinlan
and the Yale housing algorithm.
- To clarify, we're not actually
lovers. We're best friends.
- In fact, a few months after meeting Matt
I started dating his best friend
and we've been together ever since.
Boy, has that been convenient
for the three of us.
- Yup, the three of us. All three of us.
Convenient for all three of us equally.
Unlike Teava, I didn't
have the good fortune
of finding true love in
my first year at Yale.
I trust people have seen
"To All The Boys I've Loved Before."
My love life was more like
"To All The Boys I've Met At Woads
Who Puked On My Rug And Cried
About Their Ex In my Bed."
I mean, clearly one in four is not enough.
- Oh, Matt, come on. It's their loss.
You're a catch.
- Thank you.
I have to admit, I was
jealous our first semester
when I opened "Rumpus" and saw Teava
on the 50 Most Beautiful
People at Yale list.
But now I understand my worth.
I may not be 50 Most hot, but
I'm Haas Family Library hot,
which is Sterling frumpy
and Bass Cafe basic.
But CTL sexy.
- Ah, the CTL, where I
pulled an all-nighter
and had a meltdown in
front of my FOOT leader.
- FOOT! I almost forgot!
Yale's favorite cult!
Providing fertilizer to the
Appalachian Trail since 1701.
You know, I almost did FOOT,
but actually broke my foot.
- I'm sad you never got
to meet your FOOTies.
- Right? But you know
who I did get to meet?
My FroCo group.
And my TF, and my ULA, and my
CCE, and my CAG, and my PL.
- Peer liaison.
- And my PL.
- Personal librarian.
- And of course, my SSRI.
- Selective serotonin rehabilitation?
- The Summer Science
Research Institute. Yes, sir.
And speaking of science,
can I hear from all my pre-meds out there?
- Look at you, with your lab
coats and employable skills.
- I know you're at home,
but if you're pre-med,
I want you to raise your hand proud.
Great.
Now please keep your hand
up if you are available
for free or low cost tutoring.
I am still trying to
finish my science credit.
- Now, now, now.
Matt's modest, so here's
something he won't tell you.
He's an amazing student.
Since meeting Matt, I now
have an organized calendar,
better study habits, and
crippling imposter syndrome.
You know what I'm talking about.
Now, if Yale really
wants to make us normies
feel comfortable on this campus,
all they need to do is
put people like Matt
in stand-alone singles and not
let them speak in sections.
- And just to piggyback off that,
I had some tough nights at Yale.
I'm sure you did too.
But in those moments of despair,
we must remember we have a resource.
The Good Life Center.
- Feeling down? Play in a sandbox.
- Accidentally called your professor Mom?
Touch a succulent.
- Submitted fanfiction
instead of an essay?
Prof. Santos has chai on tap.
- And you know who else
at Yale has got your back?
Who will be there for you day and night?
Your personal librarian.
- Your personal librarian.
- In fact, I, oh, Teava, should I?
- Matt, she's gonna love it.
- Okay.
I actually wrote a poem in
honor of my personal librarian.
So, um, Lori Bronars,
this haiku is for you.
(clearing throat)
Orbis was no help.
Needed newspaper records.
Emailed you midnight
please help, bad grade,
fail class, no job,
law school, Dad's pride!
- All right!
- You didn't like it?
- I would critique your poetry
but I haven't read a book
since I was 10 years old.
- Teava!
- What?
I expected to read books at Yale.
I expected I'd spend hours reading
the most prolific authors in history.
William Shakespeare, Virginia
Woolf, Toni Morrison.
But instead I spent hours
reading COVID emails
from Melanie Boyd, Marvin
Chun and Stephanie Spangler.
- And that's not Yale's
only false promise.
Yale tells you that you'll
meet the next John Kerry
or Meryl Streep, but
you're much more likely
to meet their art major grandchild
at a pregame you weren't invited to.
- Yeah, I expected to
meet the rich and famous,
but all I've gotten is a $6 Venmo request
from a billionaire's child for Franzia.
- Of course the biggest broken promise
came on our first day at Yale.
In a speech in Woolsey Hall,
Dean Chun told us not to worry
about getting straight As.
You can get a couple Bs and Cs.
But what he didn't anticipate
is that we'd all be getting Ps.
- Thank you, No-Fail Yale.
The pandemic has indeed
presented many obstacles,
but we've adapted our senior year to Zoom.
- We've gone to Zinprov
shows and Zoga classes.
- Zaked parties and zisciplinary hearings.
- But most of all, we've gone to
Zale Zental Health and Zounseling.
Group zerapy, of course.
- We missed out on a lot
of senior traditions.
Society parties, Masquerade,
Last Chance Dance.
But if there's one senior tradition
that's endured these tough
times, it's Feb Club.
- You know what we're talking about.
- And in our apartment,
we found ourselves celebrating March Club.
- April Club.
- And we are in the midst of a
thrilling May Club right now.
- Right now.
But here's the thing.
Even when we're zeniors no more,
there is a club to which
we will all belong.
- The Yale Club, where for $1,000 a night
you can get a New York City hotel room
that reminds you of a Welch single.
- So win your Tonys, cure
your patients, save the world.
The Class of 2021 will scatter the globe
after we leave campus,
but we will always be
united in our memories.
- We will always be the
class that paid full tuition
to watch a Sterling Professor
speak on mute for 15 minutes.
- We'll always be the
class that lost Commons,
Wall Street Pizza, and
of course, Myrtle Beach,
which no one would go to against
COVID regulations, right?
- And we'll always be the class
that made it out in
one piece with the same
top-of-the-line education
our predecessors enjoyed.
- And some-top-of-the-line mRNA
they couldn't have imagined.
- Thank you.
- When I think about the
student organizations here,
I think about family and camaraderie.
I also think about the ways
in which we all come together
from such diverse backgrounds
to unite with the same
passions and interests.
For me, I met some of my
dearest and closest friends
throughout my time in these organizations
and will forever be grateful for that.
For me, two organizations
that stand out in particular
are Danceworks and Yale Steppin' Out,
because they're two
organizations that are part of
the greater dance community here at Yale.
And I'll really remember
every single rehearsal
and performance I've done in these groups
because these have really
helped me cultivate
deeper and meaningful
connections with people.
And I also think that there's
something so beautiful
about the energy that's created
every single time there's a performance,
because it's such a safe
and welcoming space.
And I'll really miss that.
(upbeat music)
- Think back on your
past four years at Yale.
Did they turn out the way you expected?
How has Yale changed you and
how have you changed Yale,
and are you proud of what you've made
of your four years here?
As you listen to the final speech
of this year's Class Day program,
I encourage you to consider and reflect
on your own college years
and what it means for you to be a Yalie.
Without further ado, I'm beyond
excited to present to you
this year's serious reflection,
given by Alec Zbornak,
a humanities major, of Ezra Stiles College.
- My first winter break at Yale,
I flew to Hawaii with
my improv group on tour,
and on our third day
as we were coming back
from an adventure to a roaring waterfall,
we happened to stumble upon a rainbow.
Immediately, we pulled
over, got out of the car,
and as if on cue all started
sprinting towards it,
cheering and jumping and
throwing our fists in the air
like we were crazy, we
ran towards what felt like
the perfect ending to the perfect day.
But as we tried getting closer and closer,
the rainbow kept slipping
further away from us.
Three winter breaks have come
and gone since that tour,
but the memory feels
especially relevant now.
Each of us has spent the past four years
running towards our
beautiful Yale finales.
Every 1 a.m. paper in Bass,
every late night grilled
cheese in the Buttery,
every performance, every game, every test
has been another step closer
to our senior springs,
to a colorful time that's
supposed to be saturated
with friends and parties and graduation.
And then came the pandemic,
and a lot of things changed about Yale.
No more in-person
classes, no Harvard-Yale,
no Masquerade, no Spring Fling.
It's hard not to focus on all the loss.
It's hard not to feel
like just when we were
finally going to reach our
rainbow, it slipped away.
But the more I think about it,
the more I realize it's
always been this way.
Even before the pandemic,
from the moment we first
set foot on campus,
there's always been things
that we wanted to do but couldn't.
In fact, there are whole
boards filled with them.
You can't go more than 100 feet
without running into one of these
giant rectangular
bulletin boards on campus.
Inside, outside, Old Campus, Cross Campus,
even behind Toad's, and
each is filled to the brim
with an array of glistening
flyers and posters.
In our first years, my friends and I
would stand in front of those
boards forever taking photos
of all the things that we wanted to do.
Improv-A-Ganza, Treasures
from the Yale Film Archive,
Talk Like A Pirate Day,
Wilderness First Aid Course,
Learn to Curl.
It was a mosaic of opportunities.
And just when we thought
that we'd done them all,
someone would come and
staple a fresh batch.
Civil Disobedience 101,
Yale Photo Society Fall Exhibition,
Perform with Yale Children's Theater,
Conversations with Vice President Al Gore,
the Silliman Haunted House is back!
Our camera rolls quickly turned
into a Technicolor patchwork
of club meetings and
events and performances.
But as we soon realized, we
just couldn't do them all.
Even this year with
everything that's changed,
there's still so many things
that we can't do here.
Things that we want to do,
things that we wish we had the time to do,
but things that we simply can't do.
The performance of our
friend's one-person show
interferes with the Ezra
Stiles hike to East Rock.
The YSO concert with the CCAM
virtual reality workshop.
The IM spikeball tournament
with the fall foliage tour.
Do we want free cannolis in the courtyard
or free chicken nuggets on Cross Campus?
Do we attend the virtual college tea
with the creator of
"Avatar: The Last Airbender"
or with the Nobel Laureate?
Even now there's so much to
do, so many people to meet,
and friendships to solidify.
I still think about that
rainbow in Hawaii a lot though.
There's just something so Yale about it.
From the time that we were
wide-eyed first years,
we've been chasing the
perfect college experience
where we do everything,
take advantage of every
opportunity that Yale has to offer.
Where by our senior springs,
we could be editor-in-chief of the YDN,
president of the YCC,
first chair of the YSO,
and quarterback of the football team
with four Ivy League
championship rings on our finger
and a diploma reading
"Ultra Mega Summa Cum Laude"
in our hands.
Where we've gone on every
study abroad fellowship,
watched and performed in every show,
and met and become best
friends with everyone.
We've checked off every flyer
from that bulletin board.
But that's impossible.
It's impossible to catch the rainbow,
though if we've learned
anything from this year,
it's that Yale isn't actually
about catching the rainbow.
Yale's about realizing,
even if it takes four
years and maybe a pandemic,
that you can never catch
it, and that that's okay.
Yale's about discovering
how you want to chase it.
And it's about running
and jumping and laughing
with the people you love the entire way,
because it's lovely to chase rainbows,
especially when the chase is as beautiful
and vibrant and special as it was at Yale.
- It can feel a little
cliche to talk about
the importance of community at Yale,
but the strength of those
relationships really came through
in the first few months of the pandemic
when we were so suddenly dispersed
and yet relied on each other anyway.
And it was those types of moments,
like playing late night
"FIFA" games with suitemates,
going on friends' tours of the YUAG,
or celebrating blowout
wins against Harvard
on the sports fields
which build the types of relationships
that make Yale so special
and that I know can last a lifetime.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, Class of 2021.
And on behalf of the Class Day Committee,
we hope you've enjoyed this
virtual version of Class Day
and that you've been able
to experience the feelings
of camaraderie and joy that are
at the heart of the celebration.
A lot has changed from our
first year to our last,
and I don't just mean the pandemic
that has tried to define our senior year.
in one way or another.
Our class has been the
first to do many things.
The first to live in the
brand-new residential colleges
that soon became home.
The first to experience the best YSO
Halloween Show ever produced,
and the first to see Marvin Chun's grades.
The Class of 2021 is a group
of incredible game-changers,
first leapers, and modernizers.
It's my favorite thing about our class
along with just how incredibly
passionate, strange,
and unique we all are.
And this Class Day is another
example of how we get creative
and incite change in whatever we touch.
The traditions Akhil talked
about at the beginning
are still present on this day,
but we've made them our own.
The ivy seeds you received
are part of a long tradition,
but this year you can take
them where ever you go next.
Plant them in your new homes and hopefully
they'll remind you of the
incredible last four years.
The anthology that we put
together also changed drastically,
expanding to include
different forms of expression
and hopefully encompassing as many parts
of our Yale experience as possible.
One thing that hasn't changed, though,
is the tradition of hearing
"Bright College Years"
at the beginning and
end of our time at Yale
and waving the handkerchief you received
either yesterday or even four years ago.
It's a heartwarming tradition
that allowed us to say hello
and now to say goodbye.
Therefore it's my honor to
introduce the Yale Glee Club
in a brand-new performance
of "Bright College Years."
And lastly, from all of us,
congratulations, Class of 2021.
♪ Bright College years,
with pleasure rife ♪
♪ The shortest, gladdest years of life ♪
♪ How swiftly are ye gliding by ♪
♪ Oh, why doth time so quickly fly ♪
♪ The seasons come, the seasons go ♪
♪ The earth is green or white with snow ♪
♪ But time and change shall naught avail ♪
♪ To break the friendships
formed at Yale ♪
♪ In after years, should troubles rise ♪
♪ To cloud the blue of sunny skies ♪
♪ How bright will seem,
through mem'ry's haze ♪
♪ Those happy, golden, by-gone days ♪
♪ Oh, let us strive that ever we ♪
♪ May let these words our watch cry be ♪
♪ Where'er upon life's sea we sail ♪
♪ For God, for Country and for Yale ♪
(crowd cheering)
(energetic music)
(upbeat music)
(lively music)